Привет! Прошлый урок был у нас про Mid Journey. Он классно генерирует визуал, у него куча стилистических настроек. Сегодня мы посмотрим про инструмент совершенно другой философии.
Если наш Mid Journey для того, чтобы из коробки достать сразу крутой визуал и потом его в дальнейшем где-то как-то использовать, то Kree — это инструмент, в котором можно делать всё, включая то, что делает Mid Journey, но, конечно, не на том же самом уровне.
Сегодня пройдёмся по этому инструменту, посмотрим вообще всё, что в нём есть и посмотрим, как это работает и как тебе использовать это в своём проекте.
Опять же, урок снова обзорно-демонстративный, потому что сама специфика генерации визуалов предусматривает это. Мы уже разобрали всю базу и всю теорию, мы знаем, из чего генерация визуала состоит.
Теперь мы смотрим, где это делать, где это всё осуществляется. Если Mid Journey был необязательным, то этот инструмент я всё-таки советую тебе взять.
Погнали разбираться. Крио у нас также доступно через веб-приложение, через сайт и, как видишь, тут тоже огромное
количество возможностей. Здесь даже изложены не все, то есть у нас есть лента, у нас есть мудборды, с недавним обновлением они появились.
Есть, как ни странно, генерация изображений в огромном количестве моделей. Есть real-time canvas, то есть в режиме реального
времени ты свой набросок можешь собирать, собирать композицию из разных элементов. В общем, посмотрим, как это работает.
Проверация видео, есть edit, мы знаем, что есть in-paint, out-paint и так далее. Там всё это есть и даже больше, но с определёнными нюансами.
Также есть enhance, то есть, иными словами, upscale. Сегодня мы посмотрим, где это находится, а в следующем уроке разберём,
как вообще upscale, какие модели для этого лучше подходят и что выбирать конкретно тебе. Также можно обучать свои
собственные лора модели, свои стили. Эта механика немного глубже, чем профили в Mid Journey. И также тут есть те самые ноды, о которых мы уже не раз говорили.
И давай, наверное, начнём со страницы home, главной страницы. Что здесь у нас есть? Во-первых, здесь даже немного удобнее, чем в Mid Journey. Это реализовано, тут у нас есть сразу поиск.
Мы можем ввести какой-нибудь, не знаю, product shot. Продуктовый shot. Всё, сразу, блин, огромное количество классных визуалов, каждый из которых можно забирать хоть сейчас и дальше модифицировать, обрабатывать.
Сама по себе главная посвящена именно созданию мудбордов. Тех же, что мы видели в Mid Journey, аналог их, собираем, переиспользуем в качестве стиля.
Тут всё очень похоже на Pinterest. Здесь ты уже можешь выбрать, в какой мудборд добавить. Если у тебя нет соответствующего, нажимаешь create board и сохраняешь.
Вот я хочу какой-то продуктовый shot, пока не знаю какой, но точно вижу, что из этого мне нравится.
Сдам мудборд, продукт-шат и теперь сюда добавляю продукт-шат. Сюда. Это тоже сейв. Здесь тоже это выглядит неплохо. Двигаемся дальше.
Мне нравятся преимущественно, наверное, тёмные изображения, поэтому выбираю их.
Выбираю их. Будет хорошо, если при создании своего мудборда ты придерживаешься всё-таки какой-то стилистики.
Не просто выбираешь всё, что тебе нравится, а всё-таки хотя бы поверхностно какой-то логике придерживаешься,
чтобы ему было проще его в дальнейшем воспроизвести, когда ты попросишь его изображение создать.
Итак, я свой мудборд собрал. Давай перейдём на страницу мудборда и посмотрим, что у нас там.
Здесь есть уже ряд готовых, на самом деле, классных стилистических мудбордов.
Минималистичный скетч, плёночный нуар, какое-то изображение с маркером и так далее.
Retro Web, кстати, вообще отдельно можно отметить. Очень он прикольно выглядит.
В этой стилистике здесь также огромное количество изображений, и ты свои можешь также создавать.
Я выберу свой мудборд Product Shot. Здесь у меня уже 11 изображений.
Теперь здесь он мне предлагает уже то, что, по его мнению, подойдёт под мой мудборд.
Это очень удобно. Здесь могу добавить ещё несколько изображений, чтобы уточнить, что мне нравится.
И таким образом можно мудборд собирать, а в дальнейшем потом просто брать и генерировать либо то, что тебе определённо нужно,
либо брать уже то, что хорошо работает, классно выглядит и заменять в нём изображение на своё.
Теперь мой мудборд практически готов, но помимо изображения, когда мы там что-то генерируем,
у нас ещё есть и текстовое описание, которое также хорошо работает, должно хорошо работать.
Поэтому нажимаем «Анализировать борд», чтобы он описал вкус, ключевые слова и гайдлайны вообще этого борда.
И второе – он делает самостоятельно, а третье – гайдлайны нам лучше описать самостоятельно.
Итак, ключевые слова: минималистичная продуктовая фотография, драматичный low-key свет и так далее.
И здесь длинное описание этого вкуса.
Когда мы будем генерировать с этим мудбордом, вот эти все вводные автоматически будут добавляться в модель.
Нажимаем «Generate with moodboard», нам не нужны.
Тут выбран наш мудборд, и мы в нём можем генерировать.
Но обрати внимание, что мудборд доступен и подключается только к определённым моделям.
В частности, внутренним моделям Cree.
Если мы выберем сейчас, например, Nano Banana 2, то здесь никаких мудбордов нет.
Поэтому запомним, что в рамках Cree мудборды только для её внутренних моделей.
Поставим здесь, например, 16 на 9.
Здесь у нас очень похожие настройки на MidJourney.
Скорее всего, именно оттуда они их и выровали.
Сила стиля, креативность и рандомность.
Это то же самое, что было у нас там.
Креативность – это аналог странности.
Рандомность – то, насколько будут отличаться изображения.
И Style Strand – сила стиля, который закладывается к Cree.
Ну, здесь возьмём, например, сгенерируем изображение какого-нибудь энергетика – Energy Drink.
И следом введём здесь Coca-Cola и посмотрим, как он с этим справится.
Итак, Energy Drink, Energy Drink.
Ну, здесь не получилось.
У него сразу видно настолько же красиво, насколько у нас в мудборде собрано.
Но, тем не менее, на самом деле снимки неплохие.
Сейчас дегенерируются и уже более предметно можно будет их рассмотреть.
Посмотрим.
В целом, как бы норм.
Ничего сверхъестественного.
И если ты хочешь использовать уже это в качестве готового изображения,
то лучше, наверное, в мудборд зайти и выбрать что-то из того, что там уже есть.
И потом продукт этот заменить.
Потому что сюда, например, ты не можешь закинуть изображение со своим продуктом в эту модель Cree 2
и попросить его там его помесить в сцену.
Так она не умеет.
И если мы Coca-Cola генерируем, здесь вот, например, он вообще максимально далеко ушёл.
Le aesthetic.
Парфюм какой-то, несколько флаконов.
Непонятно, откуда он это взял.
Ну, изображение Coca-Cola, да.
В целом, в наш мудборд плюс-минус ложатся, но тоже не сказал бы, что сильно хорошо они выглядят.
И ещё, обрати внимание, если мы хотим сделать что-то более стилистически похожее на наш мудборд,
мы можем style strand выкрутить на максимум, да, например.
Я вот поставил 100.
Но здесь, обрати внимание, если вспомнишь, что мы там выбирали в качестве мудборда,
то увидишь, что он всё делает слишком похожим.
То есть здесь, например, он форму бутылки изменил, она очень странно выглядит.
Тут он вписал нормально, здесь как бы спору нет.
Но почему?
Потому что здесь у нас, как и сейчас, был очень тёмный объект, который не был слишком детализирован.
Соответственно, он как бы во внимание даже не принял вот детали этой модели.
А дальше у нас уже он сильно исказил вообще сам наш объект.
Да, Coca-Cola сделал какой-то зелёный, матовый, непонятный.
И последнее изображение.
Тут он совсем уже накреативил, изменил очень сильно бутылку.
То есть, обрати внимание, что параметр стиля он воспринимает не только исключительно как стиль.
То есть мы знаем, что это комбинация освещения, сцены и прочего.
Но ещё и как описание объектов.
Поэтому, когда ты эти объекты здесь генерируешь, он при максимальном ползунке стиля, при значении 100,
приближает ещё и объекты, которые ты генерируешь, к тем, что там были на твоих референсах.
Так в идеале быть не должно, но так это, к сожалению, работает.
Если ползунок стиля мы выкрутим на ноль, а креативность на максимум,
здесь у нас вообще совершенно разные получаются шоты.
Они имеют мало общего с тем, что у нас в мудборде, но при этом как-то больше форму объекта держит.
Итак, мы знаем, что мудборды именно для крио-моделей.
Но у нас есть ещё лора-модели.
Это вообще не изобретение крии, это глобальное обозначение.
Для большого количества моделей есть возможность обучения через лора.
То есть чем принципиально это отличается?
Если мы собираем мудборды, персонализации, стили и так далее,
модели просто берут вот эти все изображения в качестве референсов и что-то генерируют.
То при создании стиля лора здесь обучение более глубокое.
Он именно ищет взаимосвязь между всеми этими изображениями, что вообще образует этот стиль.
И в дальнейшем более консистентные у нас изображения получаются исходя из этого.
Вот здесь у меня создано несколько стилей, они для разных моделей.
«Давай покажу, что происходит, когда ты нажимаешь Trend New Lora».
Нажимаешь «Обучить новую модель», ну, новую стиль.
И можешь выбрать, это будет для видео либо для изображений.
Выбираем для изображений, закидываем уже готовые изображения в этой стилистике,
либо выбираем из библиотеки, из того, что ты уже генерировал.
Вот, например, у меня есть они.
И дальше ты, ну, как-то называешь эту стилистику.
Выбираешь модель, это важно.
«Крия», «Флюкс», «Ван» и так далее.
Ты можешь экспериментировать в зависимости от того, что ты будешь генерировать в дальнейшем,
что ты планируешь создавать с этим стилем.
Однозначно здесь ответить нельзя.
Плюс модели этим меняются.
Поэтому, что я точно могу посоветовать?
«Крия» для того, чтобы получать стильные изображения.
«Флюкс» для того, чтобы он более точно твоим задачам следовал.
Остальные – «Ван», «Квен», «Затимидж» и так далее – штука сомнительная.
Если у тебя не получается сделать с «Крией» либо «Флюксом», пробуй их.
Но, в целом, начинать с них точно не стоит.
Также здесь ты можешь свою лора стиль, лора модель оптимизировать под назначение.
То есть, это либо именно стиль, либо объект ты обучаешь в форме этого объекта,
либо персонаж, либо дефолт, который как бы все сразу понемногу предусматривает.
Но, если у тебя есть конкретное значение, лучше его выбрать, чтобы оно лучше работало.
Дальше у нас дополнительные шаги.
Их можно не трогать по умолчанию, не стоят нормально.
Но это параметры, которые обуславливают то, насколько глубоко будет обучена твоя модель.
То есть, здесь можно выставить миллион шагов, огромный learning rate.
Но с learning rate здесь есть нюанс.
Если ты поставишь его слишком большим, то слишком сильно в дальнейшем
твоя модель будет следовать твоим исходникам.
Соответственно, у тебя может получаться просто одно и то же раз за разом.
Какое-то пространство для креативности лучше оставить для модели.
Поэтому вот 004, которая по умолчанию здесь стоит, это оптимальный режим.
Дальше триггерное слово для того, чтобы по твоему промту подтягивался этот стиль.
Ну, не обязательно это делать, ты там его выбираешь в любом случае.
То, насколько он много ест изображений единовременно при создании этого стиля.
И в конечном итоге он пишет, сколько будет стоить эту модель обучить.
Это тяжелый процесс, встрачиваются мощности крии, поэтому за это он просит токены.
В данном случае у меня он просит 492 токена.
Сейчас действует скидка.
И обрати внимание, при увеличении количества шагов у тебя увеличивается качество, конечно, в дальнейшем твой стиль.
У тебя улучшается качество твоего стиля, твоей лора модели.
В дальнейшем при генерации лучше этому стилю будут модели следовать.
Но вместе с этим увеличивается и время обучения этой лора модели, и стоимость здесь в токенах.
Можешь увидеть, что тут прямая корреляция.
Вот, например, мой последний стиль, созданный для крии.
Нажимаю генерировать.
И в этом стиле теперь можно что угодно создавать.
Когда ты выбираешь стиль, здесь у тебя также есть ползунок того, насколько модель должна ему следовать.
Оставлю 90% и напишу:
"Серая спортивная машина на теннисном корте.
Дождливая погода.
Вокруг мячики для тенниса".
Не забываем также, что, как правило, особенно не самые дорогие, не самые крутые модели,
лучше воспринимают английский язык.
Поэтому, на всякий случай, переведу и запущу генерацию.
Здесь у нас лора выбрана по умолчанию.
Здесь у нас выбираются лора модели.
Можем посмотреть.
Выбрать либо свои собственные, либо те, которые у нас доступны стартово в крии,
либо вообще из комьюнити, кто что насоздавал.
Уже готовые стили также можно использовать.
Все.
Благодаря тому, что это модель Крия и вообще модель Крия-1,
сейчас уже Крия-2 вышла, он сделал это очень быстро.
Сгенерировал очень быстро.
При этом всего 6 токенов было затрачено.
Это прям очень мало, учитывая, что на тарифе, который я использую, 20 000 токенов дается.
Итак, изображение хорошего.
В моей стилистике видим, что все у нас здесь стилистически между собой.
Они полностью консистентны.
Их можно прямо сейчас рядом класть.
Выглядит это отлично.
И, судя по всему, на моделях Порше обучалась Крия-1.
Поэтому на реальную машину очень похоже.
Также, если у нас нет стиля лора, который нам нужен,
мы не хотим его создавать, тратить на этот токен.
И, в принципе, нам надо сейчас просто быстро все сгенерировать.
Мы можем использовать Style Transfer.
Выбираем изображение, которое уже нам нравится стилистически.
Точно так же ставим то, насколько нужно ему соответствовать.
И генерируем что-нибудь новое.
Поле для гольфа в дождливую погоду.
Запускаем генерацию.
Посмотрим, что он нам выдаст.
В целом, как бы, плюс-минус похоже.
Но здесь у нас появляются какие-то теннисные мячи.
Цветокоррекция уже не та.
Мы видим, что здесь он немного в желтизну и в розовый ушел.
А тут мы видим, что все в одной палитре цветовой.
Ну и, в целом, результат такой достаточно посредственный.
Если выберем сейчас LoRa модель.
Тот же самый prompt.
То результат будет значительно лучше.
Давай посмотрим.
Изображения практически все готовы.
Давай вот это вообще удалим отсюда.
Нам это не надо.
Мы видим, что это практически с одного и того же фильма.
Как будто бы кадры.
Очень все похоже.
Здесь у нас еще добавляется та же дымка.
Тот же цветокор.
Все выглядит классно.
Но обрати внимание, что модели это генерируют дешево.
Генерируют быстро.
Это все круто.
Но, как правило, с такими моделями и возникают проблемы.
Например, тут у нас у клюшки для гольфа отвалилась бита.
Или как это называется.
Здесь у нас какие-то артефакты с пальцами.
Тоже он клюшку пытается просто куда-то запустить.
Немного коряво все это выглядит.
Тут у нас что-то произошло с лицом персонажа.
Вот этот зеленый блик - это стилистическая особенность моей LoRa модели.
Поэтому это нормально.
Это даже хорошо, что он его сюда добавил.
И здесь единственное фото, на котором в принципе все нормально.
Но тут такие прям одинаковые деревья.
Максимальный эффект зловещей долины появляет.
Делаем вывод, что LoRa модели - это круто.
Но LoRa модели, как правило, работают именно на диффузионных моделях.
Чаще всего, например, ее используют для генерации в каком-нибудь Stable Diffusion.
Stable Diffusion - вообще бесплатная модель.
Ты ее можешь хоть локально на комп установить.
Но в чем ее нюанс?
В том, что качество генерации, которое она предоставляет,
значительно увеличивается с объемом самой этой модели.
То есть она у тебя и 50 гигабайт на компе может занимать.
И, соответственно, мощность у того компьютера.
Она может неплохо его поедать.
Соответственно, подойдет это не каждому.
В целом, LoRa модели - это такая штука для тех,
кто локально работает с визуалом,
обучает вот эти свои собственные LoRa и свои собственные модели локальные.
Но здесь, в Cree, есть возможность сделать это в браузерной версии.
И это, конечно, огромный плюс.
Плюс и вместе с этим за 6 токенов есть возможность генерить визуал,
причем достаточно быстро.
Это вообще киллер фича.
Вот, например, поставил 1.5к, даже большее разрешение.
Он сделал примерно за 5-10 секунд, сгенерировал.
Тут уже в этот раз нет никаких артефактов.
Стилистика, опять же, точно следует.
Тут у нас немного что-то с лицом не то, но это можно поправить.
Здесь тоже проблема с лицом.
И тут тоже проблема с лицом, но оно далеко.
Доставил 4k, опять запустил генерацию.
Опять у нас все в одной единой стилистике.
Дальше, что еще у нас есть?
У нас есть Node Editor, тот, о котором я уже неоднократно говорил.
Мы сейчас ничего в нодах генерировать не будем.
Просто отметим, что это у нас находится здесь.
Откроем какой-нибудь из проектов и посмотрим, что вот у нас есть текстовый промпт.
Есть у нас отдельно продукт.
И есть рядышком Nano Banana 2 и ChatGPT, которые параллельно это изображение по общему промпту генерируют.
Здесь pkm нажимаем и добавляем новые ноды.
Например, сгенерировать изображение в ChatGPT 2.
Добавил.
Промпт, какой отдельным нодом текст описал.
Либо сюда сразу.
Захотел сгенерировать еще где-нибудь, например, в Nano Banana 2.
Точно так же к этому подсоединил.
Все.
Одновременно можешь это делать.
Но тут, обрати внимание, что, кстати, у моделей ChatGPT 2 в Nano Banana 2 уже количество токенов,
затрачиваемых на генерацию, значительно выше, чем было у нас в моделях Cree.
Более подробно этот функционал мы посмотрим, когда будем говорить о нодах.
И еще немного можно поговорить по поводу генерации изображений.
Смотри.
Здесь есть огромное количество моделей.
Какие из них брать, непонятно.
Но мы самое главное знаем, что у нас есть диффузионные модели.
Те, которые работают точнее, но при этом не так визуально круто.
Здесь при нажатии на модели ты можешь почитать про каждую, посмотреть сколько токенов они затрачивают, посмотреть примеры сгенерированных изображений с этой моделью.
Но что я еще раз здесь могу отметить.
Nano Banana 2 хорошо правит, хорошо следует твоим указаниям.
Ее точно.
Ее точно на стол кладем.
Что еще есть?
GPT Image.
В случае, если тебе нужна высокая точность текста, да и вообще эту модель значительно подтянули, можно использовать ее.
Если по каким-то причинам с Nano Banana 2 не получается.
Nano Banana Pro более точная, чем Nano Banana 2.
Она лучше следует твоим описаниям, но при этом менее креативная, визуал там слабее и работает она дольше.
И Kriya - это внутренняя модель, которая достаточно креативная.
Мы сейчас посмотрели, что она стилистически может создавать интересные изображения, но с ней тоже нужно попариться.
Но это прям диффузионная модель.
Соответственно, она непослушная, но стилистически из нее можно выжать классный результат, если не хочешь платить за Mid Journey отдельно.
Но, конечно, того же уровня результата она не даст.
Все остальное - Imogen, Luni, C-Dream и так далее.
И последнее, что тоже стоит отметить - это модели Flux.
Это модели, которые мы уже говорили.
И визуал могут неплохо следовать твоему промпту.
Поэтому их также можно использовать.
Здесь они относительно дешевые.
Flux 2, Flux 2 Pro - тоже штука хорошая, можно брать.
Все остальное - Z-Image, Imogen, Unii, C-Dream и так далее - все это ситуативно.
Вот что-то новое выходит, можно попробовать, посмотреть, как оно будет работать.
Как правило, вот те, что я описал до этого - это прям такие мастодонты на рынке и они дают самый лучший результат.
У остальных что-то выходит, иногда хайпует, но в целом догнать никто нормально не может.
Самое основное мы разобрали, у нас остались такие фичи.
Первый из них - это Enhancer или Upscaler.
Находится он здесь.
Можем выбрать какое-то там изображение, например, от Coca-Cola и его upscale.
Подробнее об upscale мы поговорим в отдельном уроке.
Эту тему нужно более глобально затронуть.
У нас есть отдельная вкладка работы с Nano-Banano, но особо смысла я в этом не вижу.
Можно вымыть, что ты считаешь, делать, я это делаю там.
Если же хочется тут, что здесь дополнительно появляется?
Во-первых, тут только две модели - Nano-Banano 2 и Nano-Banano Pro.
Здесь появляется вкладка "Контекст".
Ты можешь описать, какого результата ты хочешь достичь с Nano-Banano.
Закинуть туда референсы.
Здесь внутри нее создать такой moodboard.
Мы уже знаем, что moodboard только для крия модели можно использовать.
Здесь можно создать небольшой аналог.
Закинуть 16 до 16 референсных изображений.
Добавить описание того, что ты вообще от нее ожидаешь.
И вроде как она будет следовать твоим задачам.
Но имея в виду, что Nano-Banano 2 и Pro - это не креативные модели.
Соответственно, очень вряд ли ты получишь какой-то впечатляющий от них визуал.
Только если очень-очень подробно его опишешь.
Ну и помимо всего прочего, что может быть полезно для продуктовой съемки.
Ты можешь сюда добавлять элементы.
Создавать здесь конкретные объекты.
И затем их упоминать при создании внутри вот этого интерфейса.
Это может быть полезно.
Дальше у нас Real-Time Editor.
Это инструмент, в котором в режиме реального времени, как я думаю, ты уже понял,
можно генерировать изображение с использованием либо текстового описания,
либо каких-то каракулей, либо готовых изображений.
И помимо этого, сюда можно даже 3D-модели добавлять.
Как, например, здесь в примере показано.
Добавляешь 3D-модель, крутишь ее, и у тебя в режиме реального времени генерируется изображение.
Если я хочу, например, вот под таким углом съемку и хочу, чтобы у меня не камни были, а цветы,
то он в режиме реального времени эти цветы сюда добавляет.
Крутим, перемещаем, все у нас сюда добавляется.
Но обрати внимание, что для вот этого процесса используется отдельная модель, которая называется Real-Time Edit.
И эта модель, ну как бы тут понятно, да, что нужно генерировать моментально, много, быстро,
и результат в ней может получаться, ну там, не слишком точный, не слишком красивый и так далее.
Тут как бы вопрос скорости, что ты, по сути, вайп-дизайнишь,
собираешь какой-то визуал и в дальнейшем его потом идешь и дорабатываешь.
От этого отталкиваешься только.
Оставим, например, так наше изображение и на фон добавим какой-нибудь треугольник.
Правой кнопкой мыши можно Bring Forward поместить вперед это изображение.
Немного его увеличим и напишем Background with Mountain.
Background с горой.
Ну, здесь эта гора, здесь он нашу гору не воспринял.
Можем выбрать, например, не Mountain, а что-нибудь более похожее.
Пирамида. Background с пирамидой.
Если мы ее переместим, то и эта пирамида у нас тоже перемещается.
Тут он две нарисовал, ну, как бы опять же, да, такая модель, от нее высокой точности ждать не стоит.
Все, повернем и у нас уже какой-то набросок изображения есть, да, композиционный.
Если мы хотим выше поднять, мы это делаем, у нас композиция меняется.
Мы собрали вот первый вариант этого изображения и можем его перекидывать дальше либо на Upscale и улучшение этого изображения.
Либо в ту же Nano Banana 2, сказать ему лучше до 4К, поправь там, я не знаю, цвета, освещение, сделай сочнее это изображение, он это все сделает.
Опять же, Real-Time Editor - это не инструмент для конечного визуала, а такой итеративный инструмент для быстрого наброска и сборки композиции.
Следующая вкладка - это Edit.
Здесь можно редактировать изображение.
Мы знаем, что у нас есть InPaint, OutPaint.
Давай посмотрим, как тут это работает.
Выберем какой-нибудь ассет.
Я возьму вот это изображение с каким-то Corvette.
Смотри, здесь первое, что у нас есть, это AI Edit.
Ты описываешь просто, что ты хочешь поменять, и это меняется.
Сюда же ты можешь закидывать, в зависимости от модели, которую выбрал, изображение с какими-то референсами.
И тут ты выбираешь модель.
Nano Banana 2, Nano Banana Pro и так далее.
Все основные здесь перечислены.
Сейчас чуть подробнее об этом поговорим.
Здесь, в принципе, вот этот AI Edit, по большому счету, ничем не отличается от того, что если ты зайдешь просто в Nano Banana или в Image и выберешь Nano Banana и попросишь что-то поменять.
Принципиально ничего не меняется, поэтому эта вкладка Я Edit нам особо и не нужна тут.
Дальше.
Что еще у нас здесь есть?
Change Region.
Это вот InPaint, тот самый, о котором мы говорили.
Здесь мы можем выбрать конкретную область и внутри нее что-то поменять.
Но, обрати внимание, не все модели поддерживают InPaint.
Не все могут в определенной области рисовать и больше ничего не трогать.
Если мы сейчас выберем Nano Banana 2 или выберем ChatGPT Image, то он внесет изменения, конечно, только в конкретную эту область, но при этом все изображение перегенерирует.
Вот, например, я выберу здесь, напишу, нарисуй мне пальму.
Если мы делаем это в Nano Banana Pro, то вроде как все нормально, да, пальма там появилась, ничего особо больше не поменялось.
Но, если мы сейчас попереключаемся, то мы увидим, что, во-первых, у нас качество упало, у нас геометрия объектов тоже немного изменилась, у нас появилась какая-то странная дымка.
То есть, на самом деле, изображение меняется.
Почему оно меняется?
Потому что он его полностью перегенерирует.
Почему он его полностью перегенерирует?
Потому что Nano Banana Pro не поддерживает InPaint, то есть точечное редактирование изображений.
Если мы сделаем то же самое во Flux inPaint, который для этого предназначен, так он здесь и называется, то увидим, что при переключении не меняется совершенно ничего, кроме конкретно этого куска, где я попросил его нарисовать пальму.
Поэтому этот момент обязательно имей в виду и используй именно Flux inPaint, если ты хочешь точечно что-то дорисовать и отредактировать.
Остальные же модели при редактировании определенной области будут мне что-то менять, но будут все изображение перегенерировать.
Это принципиально важный момент.
Дальше. Annotate.
То есть, ты можешь конкретно выбрать, что ты хочешь поменять.
Например, выберем вот этого парня и напишем: "Этого чувака убери".
Если бы их было здесь несколько, то модель бы просто не поняла, какого конкретно нужно убрать.
Здесь Nanobanano 2 и другие не inPaint модели, поэтому уже знаем, что он все изображение перегенерирует.
Давай попробуем сейчас это сделать.
Опять же, визуально нам крия показывает, что только здесь происходит генерация, но мы сейчас убедимся, что это на самом деле не так.
Пока он генерирует, можем продолжить.
У нас также есть Crop и Expand.
Это обрезать изображение.
Здесь ничего сложного нет.
И дорисовать.
Это то, что мы называли OutPaint.
Отдаляем.
Добавляем поля.
Также здесь можем использовать InPaint либо OutPaint.
И дорисовываем изображение.
Здесь ничего сложного нет.
Дальше. Image Adjustments.
Это уже не и фишки.
Это яркость, контраст, насыщенность и так далее.
Также можно изменить освещение, но эта штука работает уже сомнительно.
Освещение, как правило, делает не очень естественным.
Также Draw.
Это такой режим наброска.
Например, здесь нарисовать какой-нибудь фонарный столб и сказать, здесь хочу добавить фонарный столб.
Он это сделает.
Дальше. Change Camera Angle.
Изменить угол камеры.
Здесь вот, например, можем посмотреть, как это работает.
Здесь я взял Rotate, переместил камеру, нажал генерировать и он сгенерировал такое изображение.
Обратите внимание, что детализация здесь так себе.
Цветокор поменялся.
Появилась какая-то вот эта тоже ненужная зернистость.
То есть, он использует для этого максимально простую и дешевую модель.
Соответственно, и качество получается соответствующее.
Дальше у нас Send to Enhance.
То есть, отправить на улучшение, на upscale.
Мы уже смотрели где-то вкладка.
И превратить видео, сгенерировать из этого видео.
Следующая вкладка у нас Video Lipsing.
Есть какое-то изображение с лицом.
Есть записанная голосовуха.
Мы это можем объединять, чтобы анимировать.
Но Cree - это вообще не место, где таким нужно заниматься.
Вот, например, могу показать, что я сделал перед уроком, чтобы продемонстрировать.
Привет, меня зовут Данил.
Мы сейчас на уроке, посвященном Cree.
Ну, получается, прям, мягко говоря, так себе.
Для этого есть для генерации голоса, есть Lemon Labs.
Для генерации видео есть Heigen.
Этим нужно заниматься там.
Здесь, в Cree, в этом смысла никакого нет.
Только разве что побаловаться.
Далее.
Motion Transfer - это штука схожая.
Здесь мы добавляем какое-то свое видео и добавляем персонажа.
После чего этот персонаж, повторяя движения, анимируется.
Опять же, делается это все очень слабо.
3D-объекты.
Ты закидываешь какое-то изображение, желательно, в белой сцене, получаешь из этого 3D-объект.
Потом можешь переиспользовать и при генерации в нодах, и при real-time editor, как мы сегодня посмотрели.
Штука неплохая, но тоже не стоит ожидать, что там будет невероятная какая-то модель.
И последнее - VideoRestyle.
Закидываешь видео и накидываешь на него какой-то стиль.
Тоже сомнительная штука.
Я никогда не пользовался и смысла в этом не вижу.
А, ну и последняя вкладка - Ассеты.
В общем-то, здесь все ассеты, которые у нас есть.
Все, что мы генерировали, здесь можно найти и переиспользовать.
Например, перегенерировать, превратить в видео, отредактировать, пропскейлить.
Все те возможности, что мы сегодня посмотрели.
По возможностям на этом все.
Все, давай теперь обсудим тарифы.
Что у нас здесь есть?
У нас 4 основных тарифа.
Это Free, Basic, Pro и Max.
Я рекомендую брать тариф Pro, потому что там есть ноды и, по сути, весь модуль можно закрыть вот этой вот подпиской Pro.
Конечно, круче визуал получается в Миджорне, конечно, круче ноды.
Работают в VIVI, там больше возможностей.
Но максимально экономно, вот, за 35 долларов подписки тебе хватит с головой.
Ты все погенерируешь, 20 тысяч токенов тебе точно хватит на то, чтобы попробовать все.
Это прям золотая середина.
Подписка Max, подписка попроще уже без нодов.
Подписка Max уже для тех, кто там, не знаю, каждый день что-то генерирует, профессионально работает в Крии.
Нам это не нужно.
Pro, золотая середина, которой точно тебе хватит и даже будет больше.
На этом все.
Домашнее задание в этот раз тоже без проверки.
Просто заходи в Крию и ознакомься с тем, что мы сегодня посмотрели.
Создай свой мудборд, обучи свою лоро-модель, сгенерируй несколько изображений в единой стилистике.
Если хочешь уже сейчас начать работу над своим курсовым проектом, тот промт, который мы сделали, тот промт и описание стилистики,
которые мы собрали с помощью директивы, можешь закинуть в Mid Journey, сгенерировать несколько вариантов визуала, которые тебе нравятся.
Собрать там, возможно, свой стиль, свой мудборд или сделать это здесь, в Крии.
На этом все. До встречи в следующем уроке.